la première circonscription de côte-d'or
plus convoités que jamais à droite
françois xavier dugourd ne désarme pas
alors qu'une autre candidate lui a été
préféré pour porter les couleurs des
républicains aux prochaines législatives
s'inspirant de ce qui vient de se faire
au niveau national il propose
aujourd'hui à anères chance qui a été
investi par le parti et aux deux autres
candidats déclarés de participer à une
primaire de la droite et du centre
un vote ouvert aux militants mais aussi
ou sympathisants la primaire ça
fonctionne on l'a vu au niveau national
il ya un vrai intérêt pour les français
de participer aux décisions qui les
intéressent et à la vie publique
c'était quand même une grosse surprise
il ya eu un succès populaire très
impressionnante cette primaire dont il
ya un vrai intérêt est par ailleurs
l'autre constate c'est sur cette
circonscription
on a un problème on a un problème parce
qu'on a quatre candidats de la droite et
du centre
ça fait beaucoup beaucoup trop de
candidats c'est aussi le sentiment d'un
leur chance le seul point sur lequel
elles s'accordent avec françois-xavier
dugourd selon elle cette idée de
primaires cacherait mal une dissidence
qui ne peut que mener à la déroute
je pense que c'est la tentative de
servir des ambitions personnelles et je
pense qu'on doit pas être dans ce
schéma-là la politique aujourd'hui tel
que le souhaitent les citoyens c'est
justement éviter les petites manoeuvres
politiciennes et là on est en plein
dedans et puis de servir plutôt
d'intérêt général et de façon collective
françois xavier dugourd a également
déposé un recours auprès du parti
concernant cette investiture la décision
devrait être connu courant de ce mois à
nerchio dit ne pas la redouter
[Musique]